Today's theme will be "generosity".
What do I mean by that?
Aikido is a modern budo, right?
So it's a way for the betterment of human beings.
What it means is that our thoughts, our words, and our actions should be one and the same,
so there ought to be no need to talk during practice.
Just focus on the technique.
When you practice, give it 100%. This is "generosity".
Give a 100% to your partner.
Given a 100% when you are tori,
perform your best and your most pleasant technique.
When you take ukemi, take you best ukemi,
help you partner.
That's about it.
My technique is very simple, so it'll be easy.
Mihaly, please.
Do the biggest technique possible.
Open, open.
No jerky movements like that.
Open your partner's body.
Don't use severe techniques.
You can take back falls or break falls, whichever.
Do this technique in your own way, but please give that feeling to your partner.
Open the body of the partner.
Slowly is fine.
That's it, do the biggest movement possible.
When you take ukemi, keep the contact until the end.
I don't mean hold stiffly, but hold until the end.
Not like this.
Not like this either.
But until the end.
You don't even have to hold strongly, just keep the contact.
Not like this, all stiff.
Same thing if you take ushiro ukemi.
Stay until the end.
Is that OK? A bit more please.
The movement is a bit like when you're swimming at the pool.
I'm bigger than you so do a larger movement.
Yes, like this.
Do is softly.
Not like this.
Establish the contact, and move your whole body as a single unit.
Stay soft.
You can be strong, but stay soft.
Strong and stiff aren't the same thing.
Hold strong.
If I tell him to hold strong, I'll immediately see tension in his shoulder and elbow, and they won't be as mobile.
The muscles that move the hand are connected up to the forearm, not higher.
This and this, it's completely independent.
Here, I'm stiff, everything is locked.
Here I'm strong,
I use only those (forearm) muscles.
[Move any way you like.]
Look at my shoulder,
the elbow and the shoulder stay soft.
This is being strong.
Make a clear difference between strong and stiff.
During practice, we often mean to hold strong but we end up stiffening.
We stiffen in our mind too.
Grab as strongly as possible,
but keep the rest relaxed.
Do you understand?
Whether you take ukemi or whether you do the technique, it should be the same thing.
Not like this.
Gentle contact.
Same feeling as when you hold a baby.
Treat the partner as softly you would treat a baby.
I have the same feeling when I hold my own 2-months old baby.
This is what I call a generous technique.
Same thing as for before's technique.
Stay soft.
Strong is fine, but not stiff.
Same thing when you take ukemi.
Hold strong but keep a soft body.
Before, we just saw some demonstrations of koryu bujutsu.
Of course, Aikido comes from koryu bujutsu.
The Founder of Aikido learned Daito-ryu aiki-jujutsu from Takeda Sokaku Sensei.
99% of aikido techniques come from Daito-ryu.
So you may be wondering: "What makes aikido different from Daito-ryu?"
In Daito-ryu, you immobilize the enemy at your feet and you kill him.
Done!
You do not leave any way out to the partner.
In aikido, it's different!
Same attack.
Not this...
You provide a way out.
But it's a dangerous approach.
He could come and attack you again.
That's why I want to give him a pleasant feeling.
If you provide a soft feeling, a pleasant feeling,
there is a chance he might come back saying "Can we please do this again?"
That's the difference.
For instance on iriminage.
Don't do a harsh technique.
No need for this, nor this,
just this feeling.
Same thing for ushiro ukemi.
Soft.
Same as before, not like this,
like this.
I give him a way out, I give him an opportunity.
The goal is to make him move the way you want without telling him how to move.
Make it very clear.
This is the key for removing frustration during practice.
Do it a little bit bigger.
Because I'm taller than you.
Thank you.
The responsibility lies on tori.
When I throw, I shouldn't throw there, right?
I want to go forward, but if this forward is too dangerous, I just change forward.
I don't want to see you do this.
I don't want to see this.
What does this way of taking ukemi mean?
It means that you don't trust tori.
Because you feel that you have to check where he sends you.
"Where are you throwing me?"
"Is it OK?"
It shouldn't be so.
I trust him.
The responsibility for my safety is on him.
There should be no need for this.
I'm not afraid.
I trust him so I'm not afraid.
I only look at him.
I keep the contact until the end.
Contact with the skin, and with the eyes.
[Let's do yokomenuchi]
It's the first time we meet, right?
We can communicate through the technique.
If you make a mistake,
don't say "I'm sorry".
A real apology is made when you are being careful the next time around.
Same if you're too rough.
"Oops! Sorry!"
But then on the next technique...
"Oops, sorry!"
If you do it again, you didn't mean it.
If you make a mistake, be extra nice the next time around.
Say sorry with your body.
And from that point, you can try to find out how far he is able to go.
I don't know that yet, because we've just met.
I don't know how far he can go.
I don't know if he can take a break fall.
So I will offer him a challenge little by little.
Build up the relationship.
Using your technique, while not saying anything.
If I take big steps like this, I'm really slow, right?
I'm bigger and heavier than him, right?
So I compensate with tsugi ashi.
Not too fast though, same speed.
It allows me to go anywhere, in any direction.
But if I do it like this, I'm late.
I get stuck.
So instead I do tsugi ashi.
Irimi tenkan, tenkan...
It gives me freedom.
I do tsugi ashi so it allows me to keep this vertical line.
Not like this.
It's the same for the technique we did before.
Not this.
Now my problem is to work out how far he can go.
How far can you go?
Do your best, don't give up.
Don't give up.
More.
Never give up.
Just one more.
Slowly, you can do it.
It's OK to slow down, just don't give up.
Very good, thank you.
Just slow down if you're tired.
Do whatever technique you like.
But stay strong and stay soft.
Some power is OK, but with kindness.
Not too fast.
How far can he go?
Are you tired yet?
Not yet?
There's one more class after this!
Do your best.
How far can you go?
Great! Your turn!
OK!
Dozo, whichever technique you like!
In koryu jujutsu, we close openings and create tensions.
It's a little harsh.
In aikido, we do it much larger.
We give some space to the partner
so that he can unfold his own ukemi.
We allow him to remain in control of his own ukemi, that's the difference.
In Daito-ryu we don't give him any space, straight down.
In aikido we give him space purposefully
so it makes no sense to lock the technique.
Do not close you aikido techniques.
Give him a way out of the conflict, through the aikido technique.
Don't lock down.
Open the door.
Is it OK?
That's it.
The most important hand is the hand you don't see.
When people do this, everybody focuses on this hand, the one we see.
However, it's the hand we don't see that does most of the work.
It's more effective, right?
It's the same for this technique.
No need to chop like this, just use the thumb.
Thank you very much.